day 11 of this conflict once again we're
speaking to professor michael clark our
defense and security analyst and
professor clark we're looking um today
at the advances both being made in the
north and south but let's talk in
particular about this area here around
luhansk where we're almost seeing that
perimeter being joined together by those
russian advances yeah
luhansk was the area where the russians
expected fairly easily to push push out
north they thought they'd really control
that area well they didn't but now
they're beginning to push out and
joining up with troops that have
screened kharkiv they haven't taken
khaki yet they're still fighting but
they're coming down to the uh the south
east so they will join up that perimeter
but this perimeter of their own friendly
troops was something they expected to
establish within probably two or three
days and here we are on day 11 they
still haven't quite managed it i mean
nor have they completely established the
perimeter uh around mario paul the big
issue for the russians is when are they
going to start to push north up the uh
nipra valley because to do that they've
got to take nepro nepro is a city of
about a million people it's one of the
old russian cities used to be an
armaments industry center very
industrial the regional leader of that
area has said i will make nepro into a
new stalingrad and that was the worst
longest siege of the second world war if
he means it that would be a real tough
nut for the russians to crack as and
when they begin to move up that valley
which at some point they will have to do
and it's worth saying the ukrainians are
fighting back if we look now at a closer
map of the north of the country um we
can see hostile airport which is uh just
above kiev here um
this
is a place where on day one the russians
took and the ukrainians took back yeah
i mean the ukrainians can't mount a
counter-offensive as such a big
strategic offensive they just don't have
the forces but they can mount counter
attacks they can try to take back local
areas they've certainly done it they've
certainly done it somewhere north of
kharkiv they lost hostimel airfield on
the first couple of days but they took
it back and that was not just any old
troops i mean the russians were putting
their best airborne forces into that and
still the ukrainians took it back
they've held it since it looks as if
there's fierce fighting going on there
now so the russians are trying to take
hostimal airfield and that will be
pretty important to the future of kiev
we've been looking at this map for a few
days it does look like they're making
advances around kiev like they're
starting to surround it almost yes and
and a lot of the um uh reports today are
of some fierce fighting on the edges
around the perimeters of kiev to the
west increasingly to the south and of
course these troops that are moving in
from from chernyhiv and sumi um that
again they've they've um uh gone round
those cities they haven't taken them but
they're moving towards kiev the problem
that the russians have is that if you're
invading a country that doesn't want you
there every time you capture somewhere
you've got to leave troops behind to
protect it so the troops at the front of
the push get thinner and thinner so the
push gets harder the further away you
are from your base at some point the
russians will start to run out of troops
strange as it may seem and how many days
do you think it could be before kiev is
totally surrounded well it's hard to
tell they've made very hard work of it
so far but you we have to expect that in
the next let's guess three four days
kiev will probably be surrounded and
then the next phase of this fairly awful
war will on begin to unfold
okay let's look now at another map we
have of the south of the country and we
were talking yesterday about these
ceasefire
areas mario pole home ordinarily to
almost half a million people
that seems now to actually be in place
to cease fire it seems like it's
happening today it seems to have opened
about a couple of hours ago it's only
open for nine hours this six fire is due
to finish in uh nine hours after it
started there's no chance of getting two
hundred thousand people out in nine
hours we'll see if it holds for the rest
of the day one would hope it might um
but if it's going to be successful
they'd have to keep on doing this
successive days to get any significant
number of people out of the way in
mariopol okay that's interesting if we
look at the
military advance in the south more
broadly i mean odessa we've been talking
about that too for a few days is that
the next big battleground here yeah
odessa has to be the next big strategic
target going westwards odessa is the uh
the famous old port catherine the greats
port it's like a great cosmopolitan port
it's it's a bit like marseille or the
way hong kong used to be very
pro-russian
historically right up to 2014 but it's
very pro-ukrainian now and the odessans
are saying they will defend it that will
be a very tough nut for the russians to
crack but if they do
the logical thing will be to keep on
going because in transnistria in
nextdoor moldova country next door they
have a mirror image of the donbass and
if president putin is going for broke he
might just keep on going for broke and
try to unite the whole territories of
nova russia the old czarist russia of
which odessa would be one of the jewels
in the crown
but still in ukrainian control and they
will fight for that and it may well stay
in ukrainian control for quite some time
they really are defending that city it
looks like the second world war there
already and they are committed even the
russian speakers in odessa to defending
it against this uh invasion okay thank
you so much professor michael clark so
in the north
the battle around kiev getting ever
closer and in the south odessa could be
the next big battleground thank you very
much